North Korean leader Kim Jong-un is
reportedly leaving his country by train
and is headed to Russia to meet with
Vladimir Putin this will be Kim's first
visit abroad in more than four years
well let's get more now with our
correspondent Florence she's following
all of this from Seoul flow it seems
that Kim has now left Pyongyang do we
know exactly where he's headed there's
obviously been huge speculation he'll be
meeting with Putin
well these are still unconfirmed reports
at the moment the first report was by
ytn a 24-hour broadcast channel in South
Korea that says Kim left on a train and
it's headed for the North Korean border
with Russia now another report that
we've just had is from a South Korean
major newspaper called The Chosen ilbo
and It quotes unnamed U.S officials and
South Korean officials saying that um
they very likely believe that Kim left
Pyongyang on the afternoon on Sunday
afternoon now so there's no confirmation
as to where he's headed as yet but
Vladivostok has been considered one of
the Cities he could be headed to for
several reasons this is where Kim met
Putin the last time they met in 2019 it
was the city that Kim visited on his
first trip to Russia after he had come
into power
um and Vladivostok is also where Russian
President Vladimir Putin is he's
expected to deliver a speech on Tuesday
at the Eastern economic Forum now this
the distance from Pyongyang to
Vladivostok is about a thousand
kilometers and if he were to go on a
bullet train it would be about just
about a three-hour Journey but because
of North Korea's archaic Railway system
this journey is likely going to take
more than 20 hours now back when the two
leaders met in 2019
um they wanted I think to project a a
friendship this was after North Korea's
talks with the U.S on nuclear
disarmament had stalled now this
potential meeting if it were to take
place there's already there's widespread
speculation that an arms deal could be
discussed well Flo the two countries
certainly appear to have drawn closer
and these reports of an arms dealer sure
to be a cause for concern and Seoul and
elsewhere
absolutely now the two leaders have
talked about wanting to boost
cooperation economically and militarily
there's also said to be discussions for
holding joint military drills and in
July the Russian defense minister Sergey
shoigu visited Pyongyang he was the
first Russian defense minister to visit
the country since the fall of the Soviet
Union now
if an arms deal were to happen it could
mean one or two things it would
definitely boost Russia's defenses in
its war on Ukraine and it would reduce
the advantages that Ukraine has had in
terms of getting weapons deals from
Western Nations now the other thing
that's also a major cause of concern is
what North Korea could get in return for
supplying weapons to Russia there are
concerns of course that Russia could be
parting with sensitive technology that
could Aid North Korea's nuclear weapons
program and any weapons deal by North
Korea would be in direct contravention
of U.N security Council resolution and
that's why we've heard South Korean
officials urge North Korea to not do
anything that would contravene
International norms and international
laws now but economically a deal would
make sense for North Korea it suffered
from severe food shortages if it gets
food and energy assistance and hard
currency in return that would be a boost
that it so badly needs
Florence flew there for us with the
latest from Seoul we'll be following
that story very closely for you here on
Al Jazeera for now thank you very